gérard collomb le sénateur maire
socialiste de lyon est avec nous cette
semaine bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation pour ce preuve
par trois avec bien sur public sénat et
l'agencé france presse et au cours de
cette émission vous allez répondre à
trois grandes questions premièrement le
49-3 donc finalement utilisé par le
gouvernement pour faire passer la loi
travail marketing selon vous la fin de
règne de françois hollande alors que
même des députés ps a notamment bien sûr
les frondeurs appel au dépôt d'une
motion de censure contre ce gouvernement
ensuite vous dirai à stéphanie le rouge
de la fp si pour vous emmanuel macron
doit y aller dès 2017 vous répondre et
bien sûr à la présidentielle enfin et
malgré votre soutien aux réformes du
gouvernement en tous les cas aux
réformes que tente de lancer le
gouvernement est ce que vous estimez que
le gouvernement est en train de vous
asphyxiez financièrement la question
vous sera posée par mickaël szames s
elle s'adressera bien sûr au maire de
lyon et au président de la métropole qui
pleure le million 200 millions d'euros
le milliard deux cents millions d'euros
envolés
tout ça en moins pour l'investissement
dans votre ville vous en parlerai tout à
l'heure au caire le nouveau recours donc
temps le gouvernement à l'article 49 3
manuel valls as-tu se résoudre au
passage en force on écoute le premier
ministre tout à l'heure prendre acte
dit-il d'une conjonction des oppositions
sur la loi travail la conjonction des
oppositions y compris de ceux qui ne
respectent pas les décisions très
majoritaire de l'ogc groupe peuvent
bloquer ce texte
le spectacle donné hier soir en séance
ne me semble pas rendre justice au
travail des parlementaires de tous les
bancs depuis deux mois
parce que parce que la réforme parce que
la réforme doit aboutir parce que le
pays doit avancer parce que les
relations sociales et les droits des
salariés doivent progresser le conseil
des ministres qui s'est réuni il ya un
instant sous la présidence du président
la république m'a autorisé engagé la
responsabilité du gouvernement alors
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement gérard collomb c'est un
aveu de faiblesse et d'impuissance pour
manuel valls convient d'entendre non le
49-3 c'est un outil institutionnel qui a
été couramment utilisé depuis le début
de la vème république
moi je me souviens de mon prédécesseur à
la mairie de lyon qui fut premier
ministre monsieur bart et qui gouverna
pendant quatre ans avec le 49-3 parce
qu'il était devenue minoritaire ce qui
compte à mon avis ce n'est pas la forme
c'est effectivement le fond de mesures
et je pense qu'il faut aujourd'hui que
le gouvernement aille de l'avant
c'est à mon avis ce qu'attendent les
français vous soutenez un le passage en
force
on peut pas le banaliser non plus quand
même un nom il faut pas le banaliser
mais je veux dire que sur des textes
importants sans doute un des textes les
plus importants
moi j'aurais aimé que dès le départ on a
une position plus ferme sur ce texte
parce que voyez aujourd'hui vous avez 5
millions de chômeurs dans notre pays
vous avez dans les quartiers populaires
50 % des jeunes qui sont au chômage
donc c'est un problème tout à fait
fondamentale on a des déjà trop de
retours shirt et apporter ce texte c'est
ce que vous nous dites à sous la
pression de certains goulets je suis de
ceux qui depuis le début du quinquennat
pense que la priorité c'est le chômage
que pour cela il faut permettre à noter
économie de repartir de l'avant voyez on
a perdu 600 mille emplois en l'espace de
dix ans évidemment que c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait fondamental moi je
regarde beaucoup ce que font les pays à
côté nous quand je vois effectivement la
force économique de l'allemagne que je
voie les pays scandinaves aller de
l'avant et que je vois la france dans la
difficulté actuelle je me dis
effectivement il faut réformer il faut
réformer mais certains de vos amis qui
appartiennent au même parti que vous
gérard collomb dénonce une régression
sociale qu'est ce que vous leur répondez
et sans doute qu'on n'a pas mené un
débat lorsqu'on était dans l'opposition
je les ai toujours dit si on mélange pas
les positions sur le fond on a toujours
un certain nombre de problèmes et
questions ont été posées n'ont pas été
réglés avant l'élection françois
hollande c'est ce que vous ne dites pas
sûr bien sûr si vous voulez le parti
socialiste quand il était dans
l'opposition s'est contenté très souvent
trop souvent d'avoir une position contre
en disant je suis contre la politique de
nicolas sarkozy
mais sans dire véritablement ce qu'il
allait faire quelle stratégie et la
halle est adopté et donc évidemment le
pays n'en peut aujourd'hui une autre
critique en creux de françois hollande
que c'était lui qui était c'était une
faiblesse collective pourquoi parce que
le problème au parti socialiste ça a
toujours été justement de savoir quel
serait le candidat aux présidentielles
et jamais de savoir quelle est la
politique de fond que le parti
socialiste veut mener et tout le monde
est responsable ou y ait quelqu'un par
le temps passé qui était un réformiste
avoué comme dominique strauss kahn
n'avait jamais osé dans un congrès
proposé une motion qu'ils soient ou non
musulmans et réformatrice alors mais on
peut pas banaliser 1
le recours à l'article 49 3 vous prenez
acte que ce soir quand même de l'absence
de la disparition d'une majorité de
gauche tandis à l'assemblée je pense
qu'à l'assemblée ça fait longtemps que
les frondeurs montre qu'il fait en
désaccord avec la politique permet au
gouvernement et que il ya la majorité
qui est sortie des urnes
mais avec des désaccords au sein du
parti socialiste ce qui affaiblit
évidemment totalement la position du
coup là comme vous avez envie de mener
la fronde contre les frondeurs c'est un
peu l'appel qui a été lancé par bruno le
roux où est le problème n'est pas ça moi
je dis regardez la réalité du pays
venez voir dans des villes comme chez
moi comme vaulx en velin comme
vénissieux venez voir le taux de
pauvreté dans les quartiers populaires
42% des personnes habitant dans les
quartiers populaires sont aujourd'hui en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
ça c'est les véritables problématiques
travail peut remédier à ce que le
patronat n'en veut plus maintenant mais
sûr parce que on a beaucoup changé entre
le début de la loi telle qu'elle était
présentée
et puis la loi telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup effectivement
changé moi je vois par exemple vous avez
pour les jeunes
90% des nouveaux emplois qui sont
aujourd'hui en cdt et des cdd qui pour
les deux tiers sont de moins d'un mois
ne pas continuer comme cela
des économistes le prix nobel d'économie
comme jean tirole fait des analyses qui
sont juste en disant on a le système qui
apparemment le plus protecteur mais en
fait il fait qu'il ya une différence qui
se creuse entre ceux qui sont à
l'intérieur du système
les insider et ceux qui sont en dehors
et qu'il n'arrive pas à pénétrer sur le
marché du travail jean luc mélenchon qui
appelle au dépôt d'une motion de censure
contre le gouvernement avec d'autres
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau c'est
ce qui est nouveau c'est exactement les
élus socialistes s'ils appellent
également la constitution en avoir
comment ils le font parce que vous
réagissez comme en récit boulet
christian paul dix se dit prêt à voter
pour la motion de censure de droite
éventuellement je trouve ça totalement
regrettable que ce que vous voulez je
pense qu'il a été élu avec une majorité
il savait quel était le positionnement
quand même
du président de la république on n'était
pas sur une ligne qui a été une ligne
mélenchonistes en a été élu justement
par rapport à la politique que proposait
mélenchon donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui
mais envoyait les glissements depuis
déjà quelques mois
les frondeurs se trouve en opposition
par rapport à la ligne majoritaire du
parti s'ils vont jusqu'aux mots je suis
main pour pour l'exclusion à vous savez
c'est l'électeur qui jugent in fine et
les élections sont l'année prochaine et
ils vont voir que mon avis ce n'est pas
la fronde qui peut leur permettre
fondamentalement d'être réélu jean luc
mélenchon justement il évoque une fin de
reigne crépusculaire est-ce que c'est
l'image que vous avez de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en france l'exécutif et moi
j'aurais aimé pour qu'on puisse aller
davantage de l'avant dans cette période
qu'un certain nombre de réformes par
exemple le cicr le pacte de
responsabilité et étaient faits dès la
première année parce que on voit
effectivement que ces mesures ont de
l'effet dans les entreprises par exemple
le taux de marge des entreprise et qui
avait atteint un plus bas à 22% est
aujourd'hui totalement remonter on va se
situer bientôt dans la moyenne
européenne
si on avait fait ça plus tôt
l'investissement serait reparti plus tôt
et nous n'aurions pas le chômage que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
alors l'opposition restent très vives on
l'a dit du côté des syndicats et
également par exemple jean claude mailly
pour fo dénonce un déni de démocratie il
n'est pas seul
dire cela écouter laurent baumel qui est
député socialiste
le fait de priver les députés c'est à
dire dans le fond quand même les
représentants des citoyens
les représentants de la nation du droit
de s'exprimer de dire simplement s'ils
sont tous en contre cette loi ou de
pouvoir l'a corrigée sera vécue je pense
par une grande partie de nos concitoyens
comme une forme de brutalité
voire même un déni de démocratie alors
est-ce que ça n'est pas l'exécutif
finalement qui est coupé de sa majorité
le député à l'instant et évoque le rejet
massif dans l'opinion de ce texte par
exemple oui alors moi je trouve que
l'erreur est qu'il ya eu sur ce texte
cède pas avoir eu un accord assez clair
avec les syndicats réformistes la cfdt
par exemple dès le départ et que ça a
été une erreur fondamentale de fer que
le secrétaire général de la cfdt
apprennent par la presse qui était le
contenu précis du texte et que si
effectivement on avait bâti un accord
entre le gouvernement les syndicats
laurent fabius
ce texte serait passé et on n'aurait pas
les problèmes que j'ai été que
pensez-vous de la cgt qui s'est
radicalisée comme on l'a vu lors de son
camp google de marseille récemment ben
moi lorsque je regarde le congrès de
marseille je regarde les interventions
et que les deux tiers des interventions
sont faites par des gens qui se situent
sur l'extrême gauche de la cgt je me dis
que par rapport à la ligne qui avait été
impulsée par exemple par vianney par les
grands prédécesseurs ceux qui ont marqué
dans les 30 dernières années la cgt il
ya une espèce
d'inflexion qui à mon avis est très
nocive à l'équilibré du pays pour
l'opposition il ya une nouvelle donne
politique ce soir écouter le sénateur
les républicains christophe béchu dans
ces derniers jours on a mis en scène le
fait qu'on essayait de trouver une voie
au dialogue mais ça n'a pas correspondu
à réalité donc je pense qu'il ya plein
de choses qui se joue il ya d'abord la
déception de toute une partie de ceux
qui ont soutenu françois hollande à la
presse ceux qui l'ont lâché au fur et à
mesure les verts l'ale gauche les
frondeurs il ya plus de majorité
aujourd'hui pour ce gouvernement dans ce
pays est la conclusion qu'on en tire
c'est le 49-3 sur un texte encore une
fois qui est tellement loin des
ambitions initiales que même ceux pour
lesquels il a été fait le patronat les
entrepreneurs pour essayer de libérer la
croissance dans ce pays considèrent que
le texte va pas suffisamment loin donc
c'est quand même un ratage tous les
niveaux est ce que ça ne peut pas
s'aggraver dans les jours qui viennent
dans la rue gérard collomb est ce que la
rue et les syndicats ne vont pas se
braquer encore plus
je ne crois pas que jamais on puisse
définir une politique dans la rue
voudrait il s'est passé des temps où
effectivement il ya eu dans la rue un
certain nombre d'événements
on vient de fêter le 8 mai j'ai fait un
discours donc dimanche dernier et
j'évoquais la naissance du nazisme en
allemagne où effectivement le pouvoir
était passé de la démocratie faible de
weimar à la rue et au bout du compte ça
n'a pas été l'extrême gauche qui a gagné
en allemagne mais ça a été la montée au
pouvoir du nazisme et d'adolphe hitler
donc je ne crois jamais que pour des
gens qui sont progressistes le recours à
la rue soit quelque chose de bon mais on
vous nous dites au contraire en évoquant
les pires périodes de l'histoire que ça
peut être un risque majeur pour la
démocratie
oui bien sûr aujourd'hui la violence est
toujours un risque pour la démocratie
ont aujourd'hui sur gérard collomb parle
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on voit bien que en marge
des manifestations
les syndicats sont débordés par un
certain nombre d'éléments qui
aujourd'hui apporte la violence et
veulent casser la société par par la
force
je veux dire les black blocks que l'on
voit dans tous les pays européens
sont une force profondément contestable
est regrettable donc tous les pays et
vous redoutez donc de nouvelles
violences jeudi prochain le solaire dont
j'espère que les organisations
syndicales que des syndicalistes comme
monsieur mailly peuvent par exemple
encadrer ces manifestations de manière à
ce qu'elle ne dégénère pas je crois que
c'est bien pour tout le monde et pour
les syndicats et pour le gouvernement et
pour le pays
ce qui est évidemment essentielle alors
on entend aussi beaucoup le procès des
violences policières
est ce que cette question vous semble
effectivement d'actualité est ce qu'elle
est censée ce que je vois moi c'est que
on a eu beaucoup recours dans les
derniers mois aux forces policières
voyez lorsqu'on était dans les attentats
de l'année dernière moi mes concitoyens
lorsqu'il voyait effectivement des
policiers dans les rues ils étaient
plutôt rassurés et donc je pense que le
basculement qui peut exister de la part
de certains est aujourd'hui tout à fait
regrettable je pense que nos forces de
l'ordre sont républicaines et évidemment
c'est bien comme cela
pour tous y compris pour le droit de
manifestation fin justement les
policiers eux mêmes vont vont manifester
ce sera le 18 mai ils vont descendre
dans la rue
oui c'est vrai c'est des enchaînements
qui se voulait le 18 mai côté des forces
de l'ordre non je ne je ne vais pas
manifester je pense que il n'est pas bon
de rajouter du désordre des ordres et
qu'aujourd'hui chacun devrait retrouver
d'une certaine manière raison garder
vous explique justice doit être rendue
aux forces de l'ordre ce que vous nous
dites à écouter il peut y avoir quelques
éléments qui
bon commis un certain nombre de
dérapages et cela d'ailleurs le ministre
de l'intérieur a dit qu'il serait très
ferme avec eux mais la grande majorité
des policiers
c'est que ce sont des policiers qui
respecte nos institutions et
démocratique et qui les font respecter
tout autre chose dans l'actualité gérard
collomb il ya la question du harcèlement
sexuel et de l'omerta dans le milieu
politique après les accusations visant
l'écologiste denis baupin qui est donc
visé depuis aujourd'hui par une enquête
préliminaire a décidé ouverte par le
parquet de paris son épouse la ministre
emmanuelle cosse s'est exprimé ce matin
j'ai appris comme vous hier ses
accusations d'harcèlement et je vais
vous dire franchement là dessus il n'y a
pas à transiger c'est à dire que on
parle de faits qui sont d'une extrême
gravité
et si ces faits sont avérés il faut que
ça soit réglé devant la justice et si
ces faits ne sont pas avérés il faut
aussi que ça soit réglé devant la
justice est ce qu'il ya eu une forme
d'impunité jusque là selon vous et
notamment dans le milieu politique pour
ce type de comportement gérard collomb
vous qui connaissait bien ce milieu vous
le fréquenter vous avez sans doute été
témoin d'un certain nombre de choses
en tout cas je pense que ce que dit la
ministre est quelque chose de juste
ce n'est pas tolérable et je veux dire
que les hommes politiques et les femmes
politiques ont un devoir moral ont un
devoir d'exemplarité et c'est à force de
comportement on va dire qu'ils peuvent
être remises en cause comme cela que
peut-être l'image des politiques
aujourd'hui est une image dégradée dans
l'opinion ps qu denis baupin peut rester
député selon vous après ce que vous
venez de dire que ce devoir
d'exemplarité
c'est à lui de voir ma part j'en arrive
hériter exemplaires par le passé donc
va-t-il être exemplaire dans l'avenir
c'est à lui de s'interroger c'est
peut-être aussi à son groupe politique
en tout cas ce genre de conduite est
totalement inadmissible alors ce genre
de conduite sont des délits qui pour
l'instant sont prescrits au bout de
trois ans de trois ans seulement est ce
que c'est un délai trop court puisque
les personnes qui ont témoigné
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont accepté témoigner
publiquement ses militantes élus
d'europe écologie
et donc ne peuvent plus véritablement
porté plainte
non on verra ce que l'avenir va dire il
suppose que s'il ya eu ces comportements
dans le passé ils n'ont pas cessé depuis
trois ans et de nouvelles révélations va
trouver de nouvelles révélations
deuxième partie de preuves par 3
maintenant emmanuel macron doit-il y
aller ou pas en 2017 certains de ses
amis vous en êtes un le pousse dans ce
sens
l'intéressé vous l'avez entendu inventé
le volontarisme dimanche mais beaucoup
l'ont entendu faire en creux son
portrait en faisant l'éloge de jeanne
d'arc
il n'y a pas non plus d'hommes ou de
femmes providentiels
je n'y crois pas il n'ya que l'énergie
du peuple et le courage de celles et
ceux qui se jettent dans l'action j'aime
je lave ou que jeanne soit une femme est
une femme en devenir qui n'avait rien
fait avant de se lancer dans
l'incroyable aventure devant les grands
capitaines abandonnant rien macron en
2008 net à notre invité gérard collomb
oui donc première question est ce que
vous pensez que monsieur macron doit y
aller dès 2017
je crois surtout que monsieur mac on
doit continuer dans la voie où il est
c'est à dire faire entendre une voix
originale par rapport à toutes les
problématiques qu'on a évoqué jusqu'à
présent parce que évidemment le
spectacle qu'on voit aujourd'hui n'est
quand même pas un spectacle extrêmement
réconfortant ni de la part de la
majorité ni de la part de l'opposition
voyez moi ce que je regrette dans notre
pays c'est que quand vous avez une
majorité de droite la gauche vote
forcément contre toutes les mesures
qu'elle propose que lorsque vous avez
une majorité de gauche
vous avez la droite qui votre compte et
c'est à force de cet affrontement
permanent que notre pays aujourd'hui est
en train de s'écrouler et on voit bien
par rapport aux autres pays
les gens regardent d'une certaine
manière la france avec un peu
d'inquiétude
maintenant la question n'était pas celle
ci la réponse était intéressante mais
avec question vous vous souvenez de la
question oui je me souviens de la
question est-ce qu'il doit continuer son
action
oui bien sûr parce qu'il apporte un peu
d'air frais dans ce paysage politique et
pour pour un goût
le mans qui connaît aujourd'hui des
sondages qui le placent en difficulté
moi je regarde comme vous les derniers
sondages voir tout d'un coup quelqu'un
membre du gouvernement ministre de
l'économie qui obtient des résultats de
sympathie de la part de l'opinion
publique
je me dis que c'est pas mal et si moi
j'étais à la place du président de la
république et même du premier ministre
jan courage ray emmanuel macron a
continué son action
on a pu avoir l'impression qui jouait sa
propre partition il ya eu
forme de recadrage même par le président
de la république je peux moi j'ai pas
entendu hors cadre et donc j'étais pas
là donc je sais pas si longtemps du même
publiquement par exemple manuel valls
dénoncer son narcissisme cet homme qui
vous séduit temps mais moi je trouve
simplement qu'il apporte un peu d'air il
a dit que jouer il s'agit un peu
délétère
après est-ce qu'il joue suffisamment
collectif macron est ce que là il n'est
pas en train de totalement de brouiller
les cartes on me non enfin un jurançon
croyez par rapport aux les deux papas
aux débats de fond que l'on évoqué sur
les problèmes du travail qui sont
évidemment les problématiques
extrêmement importante
valls et macron qui sont exactement sur
la même ligne
donc effectivement que l'ambition des
hommes peut amener quelque part de
l'affrontement mais l'important quand
même c'est l'avenir du pays et donc
c'est de faire en sorte que des réformes
comme ceux là peuvent effectivement
puisse entrer en vigueur
et donc il convient au moins que les
réformistes du parti socialiste puisse
essayer de se réunir et de suivre une
direction commune
en tout cas moi c'est ce que j'essaye de
défendre comme position parce que vous
même vous vous définissez comme ni de
droite ni de gauche
moi je me suis toujours défini comme un
social réformiste parce que je pense
qu'il faut réformer ce pays et que le
socialisme d'aujourd'hui ne peut plus
être ce qu'il était il y encore 30 ou 40
ans
tout simplement parce que la société a
évolué pourquoi aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron connaît un tel succès de
popularité tout simplement parce qu'il
parle aux jeunes filles et moi je suis
dans une ville où il ya beaucoup de
jeunes créateurs de des gens qui sont
effectivement dans le numérique dans la
création de start up et aujourd'hui
macron il leur parle alors que j'irais
le discours politique classique pour eux
est totalement inaudible donc ça c'est
bien d'être en phase avec ce qui bouge
dans une société ce qui va permettre de
créer l'avenir
alors vous dites qu'il ya pas de
différence entre manuel valls et benoît
lacroix y en a eu il y en a une par
exemple sur les coeurs
j'ai aidé à créer ce qu'on appelle le
pôle réformateur oui le pôle
réformateurs se réunit toujours et dans
le pôle réformateur est à peu près 50%
des gens qui sont plutôt val siens et
les autres maquereaux nist donc voilà
donc à mon avis c'est quand même la même
ligne différents voyages ans par exemple
est ce que vous vous êtes pour ou contre
la suppression de l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes
qu'est ce que dit emmanuel macron là
dessus il dit qu il faut plus tac plutôt
taxer la rente et l'héritage que la
création de richesse bah il a raison
effectivement aujourd'hui on a une
fiscalité qui taxent effectivement la
création de richesse et pas assez la
rente et l'héritage
donc voilà je suis vous étaler la
suppression de l'sf mais on peut il ne
formule pas comme ça oui mais non ils la
formule parce qu'effectivement c'est
qu'il faut un transfert de fiscalité qui
sur l'entreprise encourage l'innovation
plutôt que les situations acquises ce
qui est fait d'ailleurs de manière
courante dans les pays sociaux
démocrates
il se trouve que je vais rencontrer le
ministre de l'économie suédois dans
quelques temps c'est un social-démocrate
et c'est le type de dispositions que nos
amis sociaux démocrates ont mis en
vigueur
quelqu'un comme philippe aghion grand
économiser un de mes amis qui
travaillaient en suède à regarder d'un
peu près comment la suède c'était
réforme et c'est ce qu'il faut faire
dans notre pays vous dites y'a pas de
grande différence entre
max aue valls et que vous même vous êtes
un réformateur comme m
manuel valls néanmoins on a pu
comprendre qu'il y avait des dissensions
entre vous ces derniers temps qu'ils
allaient au delà de problème de forme
sur une possible invitation à bruxelles
l'anecdote mois il se trouve que je suis
pas quelqu'un de rancunier donc
effectivement si on vient dans ma ville
sans me prévenir
je pousse un coup de gueule ce que j'ai
dit au premier ministre je lui montre
quelle est la force de ce que moi
j'appelle le modèle lyonnais
c'est à dire la conjonction de
l'économique et du social qui réussit
plutôt dans ma ville et vous trouvez que
manuel valls par exemple n'ont fait pas
suffisamment sur le plan social on sait
que macron avait porté un discours par
rapport aux banlieues possible terreau
dans lequel peuvent prospérer des
djihadistes et c est ce que là dessus
vous trouvez que macron justement est
différent de vals et vous préférez cette
sueur sur le chômage et à deux grandes
problématiques
la première c'est celle qu'on a évoqué
sur donc la rigidité de notre code du
travail
le deuxième c'est le problème des
banlieues les fractures sociales dans
notre pays sont des fractures spatiale
et donc quand emmanuel mac on dit par
exemple que sur les banlieues
effectivement si on ne fait pas
attention si on laisse dégénérer les
problèmes si on fait que 80% des jeunes
se retrouvent finalement sans accès à
l'emploi
alors pour le coup il y aura une
idéologie de la désespérance qui va
s'enraciner
sur ce terreau alors vous êtes prêt à
l'accueillir à lyon emmanuel macron il
devra venir le 2 juin d'accord mais pour
un mandat électoral c'est la présidence
de la république où serait la mairie de
lyon
qu'est ce que vous en dites est ce que
vous vous voyez un jour
a lyon je ne sais pas on n'a jamais
parlé vais vous y songez au sens oui oui
qui est la vie lyonnais sait depuis ce
qui est la vie nationale et donc je
pense que les carrières locales se font
sur l'enracinement dans le terrain je ne
vois pas emmanuel macron pour le moment
ça peut peut-être arriver courir
l'ensemble des marchés de la ville tous
les week-ends et passer son temps à
résoudre les problèmes pas encore aussi
écouter sur mire sur son positionnement
un que vous défendez écoutez l'analyse
du politologue jérôme sainte-marie alors
on évoque les l'elysée depuis quelques
minutes mais pour marie il pourrait
avoir en fait d'autres visées ont
l'écoutent se positionne de toute façon
idéalement pour être dans un ticket avec
un candidat à la présidentielle
c'est-à-dire pour être soit le premier
ministre d'un président de la république
de gauche soit et si françois hollande
est au second tour face à marine le pen
il aura besoin d' emmanuel macron pour
incarner justement le rassemblement de
toutes les forces libérales et
inversement si c'était la droite qui
était face à marine le pen ce serait
effectivement une très belle opération
pour elle d'annoncer que le premier
ministre
futur sera emmanuel macron c'est pour ça
que je crois que la démarche politique
actuelle des manuels macron en apparence
est destiné à la présidentielle en
réalité il vise je pense surtout
matignon vous voyez qu'est ce qu'ils
devraient faire à léon par rapport à
l'analyse qui est faite par un
politologue et minorent vous le voyez
effectivement premier ministre est
compatible avec la gauche et la droite
je pense qu'à un moment donné le
président de la république le futur s'il
réussit à gagner par rapport à marine le
pen puisque tout le monde se dit
finalement que ce soit quelqu'un de
gauche quelqu'un de droite républicaine
il va être élu au second tour par
rapport à marine le pen pour faire
attention
on a vu par exemple ce qui s'est passé
en autriche et donc la vague du
populisme qui peut tout balayé après
supposons qu effectivement un président
républicain soit élu
c'est quoi son véritable score dans
l'opinion publique c'est les 25 et les
28%
il aura eu au premier tour et donc s'il
n'est pas capable de créer un vaste
rassemblement
eh bien il se retrouvera très vite au
bout de six mois avec les mêmes
difficultés que celles que connaît
françois hollande aujourd'hui êtes non
moi je plaide pour gay effectivement il
y ait un grand rassemblement qui
permettent à notre pays de repartir de
l'avant
donc si possible par exemple un
gouvernement d'union nationale en tant
que tel et pas seulement un gouvernement
avec des personnalités d'ouverture de
l'autre mais pas forcément si vous
voulez je pense qu'il ya des gens qui à
gauche n'irai pas à droite néron pas non
plus on vous écrit un certain nombre de
gens qui sont capables de porter un
projet commun vous voyez à lyon si ma
ville va de l'avant
c'est parce qu'on a rassemblement qui
est extrêmement large
j'ai à la fois des gens qui sont d'une
sensibilité proche du parti communiste
et puis des gens qui sont en même temps
de centre-droit voire même de droite
républicaine et donc nous portons un
projet commun pour la ville et ça marche
pas trop mal donc je pense que ce qu'on
peut faire pour une grande agglomération
comme lyon on peut le faire aussi pour
impayés vous même vous pourriez être
ministre d'un
un gouvernement avec juppé comme
président par exemple vous avez vu c'est
pas la question et qu'il faut je suis
très bien à lyon
personne ne me fait signe je suis
tranquille dans mon coin
il n'est pas inenvisageable cocker temps
humain que vous soyez par exemple un
jour ministre les unions
oui pour jouer l'agglomération lyonnaise
donc on en parlera tout à l'heure j'ai
maintenant on est septième ville en
europe aux côtés de villes comme
barcelone manchester munich dont je
rêvais ayant encore une dizaine d'années
donc ça suffit à mon bonheur bon il est
l'ancien c'est d'être heureux dans la
célèbre avion comme partout ailleurs
générations se croisent
rappelons néanmoins cette recomposition
que vous appelez de vos voeux c'est très
clair avec une alliance entre la gauche
et la droite au sur un pivot central
il faut l'annoncer avant l'élection pour
vous je crois qu'il faut que
effectivement ceux qui seront candidats
disent un moment donné ce qu'ils vont
faire
même si ça paraît difficile voyez moi
lors des dernières élections municipales
j'ai annoncé avant les élections que
j'allais augmenter les impôts et donc
c'est parce que nous avons à lyon le
courage d'annoncer ce que nous allons
fait que peut-être nous gardons la
confiance des électeurs vous êtes
totalement en opposition si on vous
entend bien avec par exemple discours de
le foll qui explique qu' il faut au
contraire réactiver le clivage droite
gauche et que c'est en ressoudant la
gauche que l'on peut espérer conquérir
le pouvoir
moi mon problème c'est de savoir quand
on conquiert le pouvoir pour mener
quelle politique derrière si la conquête
du pouvoir c'est simplement pour
conquérir le pouvoir
moi ça ne m'intéresse pas j'ai toujours
des à lyon je préfère perdre sur une
ligne claire défini que de gagner dans
des espèces de jeu un peu flou et je
pense que pour le pays aujourd'hui il
faut effectivement de la clarté et c'est
peut-être parce que depuis
cinq ans on a manqué de clarté que le
rendez vous avec les français a été
ratée de clarté sur le programme et des
cafés politiques de calais sur la
politique et les alliances ya beaucoup
de gens qui disent qu'aujourd'hui le
système quand même institutionnels
français qui fait qu'un blocage
fondamentale entre deux camps bien
séparés c'est peut-être ce qui nuit le
plus gravement au développement de notre
pays et dans tous les camps il ya des
gens qui se posent cette question est ce
que françois hollande peut être le
candidat de cette clarté je vais
retrouver des déclarations de vous même
sur ce plateau en 2014
vous disiez que vous étiez favorable à
une primaire parce que votre vieille que
hollande
voilà atteignez de tel degré
d'impopularité que ça devenait compliqué
pour lui
est ce que vous êtes toujours dans cette
disposition est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faudrait une primaire je me souviens
bien des interrogations qui était posée
à ce moment là je disais pas exactement
cela disait soit il reconquerra
l'opinion publique et donc dans ce cas
là il sera le candidat naturel soit
effectivement et laura encore au moment
de la prise fin de ce qui pourrait être
une primaire des difficultés et dans ce
cas là il y aura forcément une primaire
et on le voit bien aujourd'hui soit il
réussit dans les 8 10 mois qui viennent
à inverser le sentiment qu'ont les
français de la situation du pays vous y
croyez à ce moment là il sera candidat
soit effectivement il ne pourra pas le
faire et il ya d'autres candidats qui ne
demanderont pas l'autorisation et qui se
présenteront quoi qu'il arrive alors on
reparle des manuels macron propose
d'écouter la critique acerbe de roger
karoutchi sénateur les républicains pour
le moment monsieur macron des cinq
grands escaliers du casino de paris il
est il est dans
le côté voilà sympa dégagé il et il a ce
côté je suis une star je le sais je suis
membre du gouvernement mais pas tenus
par la solidarité gouvernementale je
suis pas vraiment manque du ps joue à
gauche peut pas tant que ça je suis pas
à droite mais pas tant que ça tout ça
est donc quand même un flou artistique
qui peut rassembler tout le monde
évidemment ce serait plus compliqué si
par exemple par aventure monsieur macron
disait je suis candidat à la
présidentielle voilà mon projet bien
qu'il dise des choses précises et là mon
avis les clivages sont retrouvés une
bulle
nous on descend pas les escaliers mon
ami thierry frémaux qui dirige
l'institut lumière va monter les marches
demain donc nous on préfère monter les
marches que les chambres des escanaux
arnaud montebourg montrent le mont
beuvray lundi excellente transition
qu'est ce qu'ils pensaient de cette
possible candidature de montebourg elle
vous semble
effet comique comme il le souhaite moi
je me souviens de la campagne d'aidé des
primaires pour la présidentielle et donc
arnaud montebourg disait cette époque
que l'on allait faire la
démondialisation c'est plus difficile à
faire dans les fêtes qu'a prononcé dans
les mots et donc moi je regardais les
politiques qui ont été amenées et je
m'aperçois que c'est difficile vous
voyez par exemple si on se repenser un
certain nombre d'épisodes sur la
sidérurgie
on voit par exemple que le problème de
la sidérurgie française par rapport à la
sidérurgie chinoise
la problématique est un peu plus
difficile que simplement dire voilà il
faudrait faire ceci nationalisées et on
a résolu tous les problèmes
non les problèmes aujourd'hui sont un
peu plus complexe que cela merci
stéphane est un petit quizz pour
terminer vous répondez par oui ou par
non sur le supprimer l'impôt sur la
fortune vous avez déjà dit oui vous avez
expliqué don à la rente
alors voilà non la salle indique
simplification du code du travail vous
dites prix l'indemnité chômage
dégressive après 12 mois
oui ou non si on a le bon goût mais qui
n'est pas le cas oui avec décide la
retraite porté à 65 ans dans dix ans si
vous voulez
oui ou non la pyramide démographique
elle évolue donc il faut que tellement
ri comme on devient plus fort a bien
travaillé un peu plus l'allègement de la
fiscalité des revenus et votre retraite
une sas a déjà fait enfin dernière
question sur l'allègement de la
fiscalité des entreprises et des ménages
vous dites oui aussi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas être dans la
démagogie extrême qu'on avait besoin de
retrouver des marges pour les
entreprises mais qu' aujourd'hui dire je
vais faire comme cela des réductions
d'impôts sans regarder effectivement
rare entre elles
ça ne sommes pas extraordinaire un bon
s'ils veulent y en a peut-être en parler
dans la table numérique toutes les
propositions d'alain juppé vous êtes
quasiment d'accord sur tout voyez vous
pourriez de son ministre un jour mais il
pourrait être celui je sais pas moi de
dévaler le macron ducouret ou de
françois la haye pour n en sait rien de
lui vous allez l'invité à les troisièmes
parties de preuves par 3 à mickaël
szames s de public sénat va nous
rejoindre maintenant gérard collomb pour
vous interroger alors le com comme maire
de lyon et président de la métropole
question est ce que vous estimez être
financièrement asphyxiée par le
gouvernement dont vous saluer les
efforts de réforme vous l'avez dit mais
le gouvernement qui a baissé vos
dotations budgétaires
une baisse que vous estimé à 1 milliard
200 millions sur cinq ans
mais globalement le secrétaire d'état au
budget christian eckert qui se félicite
de ces choix bien sûr et qui sont plein
de vertus ans les côtes
la baisse des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités
on l'avait présenté comme une
catastrophe en disant si l'état donne
moins d'argent aux collectivités elles
vont avoir des recettes qui vont
diminuer les résultats 2015 prouve le
contraire
je dois le dire très clairement les
dotations de l'état représente en gros
20 à 25% des recettes des collectivités
locales elles ont baissé 2,3 milliards 7
oui en 2015 et nous prévoyons de l'ibsr
de son biais haussier en 2016 et nous
prévoyons de le faire la même chose dans
le midi 7 néanmoins le reste des
recettes des collectivités locales
produit des impôts que le produit de
l'activité des collectivités locales ce
monde impôts indirects qui vont en
direction des collégiens ont permis que
leurs recettes continuent à progresser
alors voilà donc le diagnostic posé
le ministre bon soir bon sens michel
vaujour gérard collomb je crois que
monsieur kert il n'est pas en accord
avec le président de la république
pourquoi ça parce qu'il me semble que le
président de la république qui veut
faire une annonce l'association des
maires de france comme quoi peut-être on
va peut assouplir la baisse d'impôts et
que peut-être on va remettre en cause
alors ils arrivent par de la notation
globale de fonctionnement la pression
s'est un petit peu plus non simplement
j'écoute ce que disait le premier
ministre et le président de la
république lorsqu'ils reçoivent des
associations d'élus locaux
vous espérez que le président de la
république en quelque sorte vous fasse
un cadeau c'est le moment il paraît
qu'il en fait un peu en ce moment je
sais pas en tout cas semble en tout cas
quelque chose d'utile parce que ce que
me dit monsieur kert et alors là je
m'inscris en faux contre lui et je veux
dire qu'on peut mener un débat quand il
ne le veut aujourd'hui vous allez avoir
une baisse de l'investissement des
collectivités locales qui va être
relativement forte
et vous allez le voir dans les deux
années qui viennent et vous attendez le
ministre et vous dit ça va mieux vous le
constater ça va ça va mieux
bah oury bah je peux vous dire est ce
que j'ai nous sommes cinquante neuf
maires dans ma communauté urbaine il
peut les prendre les uns après les
autres
il y en aura aucun qui va lui dire que
c'est pas hyper compliqué de boucler un
budget est là pourquoi je vous dis que
ça va mieux et vous vous dites ça va
peut-être moi je l'invite à venir quand
il veut à lyon pour le coup et on lui
montrera effectivement les budgets et
les efforts que l'on est obligé de faire
qui sont extrêmement difficile et fort
ce sur quoi exactement ceux par exemple
concret des sur le faisons nous de
donner par exemple si vous voulez sur
toutes les associations politique de la
ville on en parlait tout à l'heure on
est obligé de baisser les subventions
notre budget nous c'est moins 8%
2 sur les recettes sur l'année ouais sur
sur les chaque année et chaque année
supplémentaire donc on est obligé de
faire des économies extraordinaire
faucon faut qu'on gagne à peu près 40
millions d'euros par an je peux vous
dire que partout tous les maires de
france
tous les présidents alors je ne parle
même pas de deux conseils généraux sont
aujourd'hui en train de serrer
absolument tous les boulons et que
l'investissement va se ressentir
vous avez inauguré à des prêts à un
frein à la reprise de la croissance dans
notre gueule lyon à renoncer à des
projets par manque de financement alors
que vous savez vous tourner vers le
privé
oui non si si par exemple
aujourd'hui on avait un projet d'un
bouclage d'un périphérique on sait pas
trop comment le financer aujourd'hui est
donc donc vous pourriez en train
d'essayer de essayer de trouver des
solutions mais c'est effectivement
extrêmement difficile vous parliez de
frein à la croissance c'est ce
gouvernement qui met donc des freins à
la croissance sur le terrain aujourd'hui
sur les territoires je pense que on peut
pas vous le soulignez tout à l'heure à
la fois annoncé tous les jours que le
gouvernement dépense un peu plus d'an
tell tale tel ou tel secteur et faire en
sorte que les seuls qui soient amenés à
faire des économies drastiques
ce soit les collectivités locales je
vous le dis parce que je les dis au
président de la république je l' ai dit
au premier ministre et je le répète
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation extrêmement compliquée vous
êtes dans un dialogue de sourds à la
fois avec françois bachy
non je vous lis que j'espère que
monsieur kert se trompe sur le
diagnostic qu'il fait la politique qui
sera menée dans les prochains vous devez
bourrier quoi de la part du président de
la république à la fin du mois quand il
se présentera devant les maires mais
qu'il annonce effectivement que cela
fait trois années de baisse des
dotations que la quatrième année pour
faire un palier où il peut le faire oui
vous voulez aussi profité de l'année
préélectorale
c'est pas de l'année préélectorale parce
que là on n'est pas sur des mesures
d'apparence
on est sur des mesures qui font
effectivement que l'on doperait la
croissance
alors on verra s'il y aura une union
sacrée en quelque sorte entre la gauche
et la droite au congrès
de la mfr la fin du mois comme c'est
vrai alors que toute la gauche et toute
la droite j'en suis à peu près sûr mais
la véritable réponse oui c'est ce que
nous on a fait à lyon
c'est à dire une réforme des
collectivités locales moi je vous
rappelle que la mettre pour la métropole
nous sommes les seuls effectivement à
avoir supprimé un niveau dans le mille
feuille administratif comme ça
effectivement on peut réduire la dépense
publique pas de manière la métropole
c'est l'alpha et l'oméga c'est là où on
fait des économies
bah tout le monde peut faire ça ça veut
dire que c'est plus dans les réformes de
structure par exemple ce qui est en
train de se passer d'ailleurs dans le
développement de l'intercommunalité les
robots commune voilà dans les
regroupements de communes qu'on peut
effectivement faire des économies sont
plus dans l'avenue à lisa sion elles
n'ont plus le choix ces communes
aujourd'hui ciel seront mon avis on être
elles vont être obligés de le faire où
ils vont être obligés de mutualiser moi
je le vois bien dans l'agglomération
j'ai une discussion qui est aujourd'hui
se passe entre mémère en dix ans la
réponse qu'on va essayer de donner c'est
que nous on s'occupera de construire et
de faire fonctionner la bibliothèque
toi tu feras les équipements sportifs
toi tu feras autre chose et ils se
répartissent les choses justes comme
cela est ce que vous êtes pour la fin
des départements
alors j'ai toujours une position
extrêmement claire c'est que en zone
urbaine les départements n'ont pas
forcément de légitimité par contre dans
les zones rurales
c'est eux qui peuvent effectivement
porté la croissance
voyez par exemple lorsque vous êtes on a
raté une occasion avec la plus grande
ville qui fait 9000 habitants c'est pas
la ville qui va porter la croissance
ça ne peut être que le département et le
département regrouper honorât j'ai eu
l'occasion pendant la luano autres alors
à moi je pense qu'on n'est pas allé
assez loin et qu'on surtout on avait
pris le problème du mauvais côté en
voulant faire une réforme uniforme sur
tout le territoire
c'est pas comme cela que les choses
peuvent marcher alors on verra cette
union sacrée à l'oeuvre à la fin du mois
donc au congrès des maires de france on
va voir si françois baroin le président
les républicains de cette association
dit exactement la même chose que vous
charge est trop lourde la méthode n'est
pas acceptable et et l'issue est
désormais à peu près certaine c'est à
dire le fait que les communes ne
joueront plus leur rôle d'agents
économiques c'est-à-dire de restituer
l'argent du contribuable à travers de la
commande publique pour soutenir des
entreprises pour soutenir
l'investissement et donc pour soutenir
les créations d'emploi tant que cordiale
avec françois baroin avec la droite
oui mais j'ai dit avait à françois
baroin je dis attention libyen les
programmes
monsieur entendions par exemple plus de
100 gwh en faire 50 milliards mais veut
faire 100 milliards d'économies sur les
collectivités locales
donc là on est déjà à moitié mort s'il
fait ça ce coup là il y en aura plus
assez ce qui vous ramènera dans le camp
de la gauche alors à jamais candidat aux
primaires c'est ce qui me ramène la
primaire le fait qu'on ait une vue
j'irai assez réaliste de la situation et
du pays à la tête de la région de votre
région il ya aussi une personnalité
importante chez les républicains
c'est leur wauquiez il est assez
critiqué par la gauche et vous vous le
critiquez le révoquer
moi j'attends de voir ce qu'il va faire
quelle est la politique qu'il va mener
aujourd'hui je ne la connais pas il n'a
pas pris de mesures qui soit
significative
je ne connais pas le détail de son
budget et donc moi et me jugent toujours
pour le moment il n'a pas mis en oeuvre
beaucoup de réalisations
j'attends de juger sur les faits pour
moi l'intention la vérité de l'intention
c'est l'acte et j'attends de voir les
actes et les actes ce sont d'abord les
budgets
vous avez vu tout ce qu'il a dit à
propos du rsa de ce cancer et c'est ce
qu'il fait dans la réalité voyez par
exemple il va avoir la formation
professionnelle c'est un excellent sujet
aujourd'hui l'artiste un exemple dans
mon agglomération nous avons quarante
quatre mille personnes au rsa faire en
sorte que nous qui gérons l'assertion
que lui qui gère la formation
professionnelle on essaye de réduire le
nombre de personnes au rsa est de faire
en sorte que ces gens aillent vers un
emploi ça c'est les véritables
politiques et moi c'est ce que je vais
lui proposer etc
dessus on viserait l'action de la régie
la com et vous avez appelé à de
nouvelles alliances politiques dans la
séquence précédente gérard collomb vous
vous sentez un partenaire éventuel de
laurent wauquiez qui est effectivement
comme assez controversé à gauche j'ai
l'année je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
adhèrent totalement au projet politique
de réunion oui je prends le temps de la
belle année au parti socialiste romand
c'est pas le temps de la belle alliance
que c'est à la mode en ce moment au
parti socialiste
bah il faut que non seulement l'alliance
soit belle et qu'elle soit grande alors
manuel valls a présenté on en a parlé un
tout petit peu tout à l'heure un vaste
plan contre la radicalisation
cette semaine votre ville votre région
également est souvent critiquée par une
forme de radicalisation ce que cela vous
inquiète
oui on va dire que c'est pas la région
la radicalisation est la plus forte
lorsque je vais car c'est quand même
vivement
donc dans le pays je me fais plus de
souci pour le moment sur toute l'île de
france que sur l'agglomération
justement parce que on a réussi à créer
la métropole donc avoir une stratégie
qui soit une stratégie globale
je pense que petit à petit en tout cas
c'est le sens de la politique que l'on
mène on essaye de faire en sorte qu'ils
aient pu une division entre les
quartiers paupérisés les autres et que
là où par exemple il n'y avait que du
logement social et où là où des communes
où les quartiers étaient en train de se
paupériser de se ghettoïser en ramène
des couches moyennes et que par contre
dans les opérations emblématiques de
l'agglomération comme par exemple la
cour est logique et on met de 30 % si on
ne prend pas garde à ce que le message
républicain de solidarité de fraternité
s'applique
un jour oui nous aurons des difficultés
alors il ya des craintes pour la
sécurité à la proche de l'euro lyon bien
sûr avec son magnifique stade va
accueillir des marées vertes 1 j'ai mis
dix ans pour le verre 10 ans qui monte
quand même que même dans la tournante
il faut continuer à aller dans l'avancée
dans un mois pile et vous allez
avoir des fans zone seul agrès
rassemblement de tous les fans pour voir
les matchs devant un écran sa place
bellecour trois semaines de match il n'y
a pas une crainte pour la sécurité on en
plein état d'urgence
gérard collomb je vous rappelle que nos
jours bien que nous avons à lyon une
fête des lumières est annulé le 8
décembre et que j'ai du fait que j'ai
annulé par une décision qui n'était pas
facile alors été annulé au mois de
décembre peut avoir lieu au mois de juin
a tout simplement parce que si vous
voulez la fête des lumières elle se
passait dans toutes les rues de lyon et
vous aviez un million de personnes par
soirée là la fan zone c'est à peu près
vingt mille personnes et donc vingt
mille personnes où on travaille
aujourd'hui tous les jours pour assurer
la sécurité
voyez c'est alain juppé qui préside le
club des villes ils vont accueillir un
des problèmes sur lesquels on travaille
aujourd'hui en permanence avec le
gouvernement avec nos préfectures avec
nos polices municipales pour assurer la
sécurité avait eu des assurances de la
part du ministre de l'intérieur vous
avez eu des rallonges budgétaires mais
je pense que le gouvernement se rend
compte de l'ampleur de l'enjeu et que et
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement il convient d'assurer à
tout prix la sécurité et sur ce sujet je
vous propose d'écouter ce que disait ce
matin patrick kanner le ministre des
sports et bien lui il trouve que le fait
d'avoir des fans zone est justement
rassurant oui c'est vrai qu'un élément
de sécurité les fans zone parce que
comment voulez vous accueillir 7,8
millions de personnes en dehors des
stades si on n'organise pas les choses
et donc tu es fan zones seront
extrêmement sécurisé et d'aigus déminage
des drones de la vidéosurveillance de la
palpation pour toutes les entrées quand
on est dans la fanzone on est en
sécurité
c'est plutôt sécurisant comme dit le
ministre qui a raison
ce que je vous disais plutôt que d'avoir
des gens qui déambulent dans les rues un
peu partout vous rassembler sur un lieu
où vous montrerai les autres marques
voyez par exemple être un beau match
bellecour rien n'arrive
valve qui joue aujourd'hui moi je me
disais il ya voir personne on m'annonce
trente mille supporters qui vont venir
donc évidemment qu'il vaut mieux les
rassembler et assuré que des riverains
parce que trois semaines de bataille le
court lui le prix des loyers autour de
la place bellecour va monter dans les
prochaines semaines avec va falloir
justement que je regarde qu'il verse
bien la taxe de séjour et les arbitres
mais des événements comme ceux-là voyez
que c'est des événements considérables
vous avez des centaines de millions de
spectateurs qui vont regarder la france
au travers de ces grandes villes au
travers des nouveaux équipements et qui
donc vont avoir une belle image de la
france york et avoir une belle image de
la france dans le monde
c'est essentiellement une minute pour
éviter le recours à nyon de l'ol oui
l'ol qui est qualifié pour la ligue des
champions ça veut dire donc qu'on peut
réussir sans le gaz et son pétrole
ça veut dire effectivement que si on a
de la volonté on peut aller de l'avant
vous devriez on a connu toutes les
phases label plupart il ya dix ans puis
les difficultés puis les difficultés à
construire ce stade
et hier on nous disait à ce stade c'est
nuisible pour l'environnement ne
trouvera pas de stationnement
aujourd'hui tout le monde me dit ce
colon qu'est-ce qu'il est beau sociale
donc qu'est-ce que tu fais de celui ci
c'est d'aller toujours de l'avant et
qu'est ce qu'on disait de l'équipe de
l'équipe
oui déjà simplement fin décembre début
janvier lorsque l'on a joué le dernier
match à gerland qui avait un feu
d'artifice on avait été battu ce jour là
et là le graphique on a lancé hier
c'était évidemment terminée sur une
victoire fantastique 6 à 1
je n'avais jamais vu cela aucune
situation est désespérée c'est comme en
politique
vous avez totalement raison et le
journaliste je crois que c'est pareil
merci à vous merci merci à tous vents
soirée a très vite